you guys hear about that uh that that
cow Farm or whatever that blew up what
was it 18 000 cows how much how many it
was they burned to death or something
well yeah where's that so I don't know
you guys do you guys know where it was
someone looking to look it up because I
don't have the story pulled up but we
just started talking about you know war
and collapse and all that stuff and then
what I'm seeing from a lot of
commentators I'm seeing from a lot of
older people that are saying like all of
my life I have never seen this many food
plants and you know Farms blow up burn
down or otherwise just be destroyed that
was in Texas actually it was in Texas
yeah people and and I'm seeing people be
like it feels like something else is
going on here and we're talking about
Ukraine Ukraine's the breadbasket of
Europe I gotta wonder how much of this
may be intentional intentionally
disrupting and taking out food supplies
like what are the chances I'm not saying
it's true I'm saying what are the
chances that powerful Global Elites fear
climate change to the point that they
would actively destroy food plants farms
and Ukraine the breadbasket of Europe
for the purpose of reducing food supply
and limiting population growth again not
saying that's true I'm saying like all
of these things seem to be happening so
I'll put it this way whether or not
there's any Grand conspiracy there
because I don't see any evidence for
that I'm just saying that food plants
are being shut down through fires cows
are burning to death chicken farms all
of that stuff and then you've got the
Ukrainian War you've got the it was a
Dutch Farmers being told to stop farming
all of those things happening at once
and I'm like whether it's on purpose or
otherwise food production is shutting
down I think one of the phenomenons at
play there with those sort of Elites
isn't necessarily like you I haven't
seen evidence of it although I've read
most of of class Schwab's books and what
there is evidences is that it has a
completely different set of priorities
and if your priority is to defeat this
great a supposed climate apocalypse you
just forget about the other things so I
think that's maybe more more at play and
that's certainly the case in the
Netherlands with the the Dutch farmer
revolts where they just prioritize their
green policy completely neglecting the
uh the farmers themselves and and that's
why they they stormed up against yeah
and there's an example in California
with them shutting down gas powered cars
there's like by 2035 they're not going
to sell gas fire cars but then they say
hey we're having a we're having a heat
wave don't charge your electric car
please uh the short-sightedness and
heavy-handedness of motion with
government sometimes it I agree with you
what's here at church
I think it's done on purpose to be
honest with you sorry Bill you're well I
was just it's interesting that you
actually read class Schwab's books I
want to hear a little bit more about
that like what is his what's your
feeling from him reading the most
terrifying thing and and if there's one
book to read it's uh it's the it's not
the great reset it's the great narrative
live because in this book
he tries to create what is essentially a
new quasi-religion with a new moral
structure in fact there's even a chapter
called morals and values where they into
they they replace the metaphysic that
normal religions have let's say with a
god with climate catastrophe and I mean
the all of his literature is a total
joke you know he keeps saying I don't
want to catastrophize but throughout all
of it it is like climate catastrophe
climate catastrophe climate catastrophe
so and that's the new God he's trying to
create and he's trying to build a moral
structure on top of that and that's how
he's trying to unite the world instead
of essentially it sounds like
the perspective is correct me if I'm
wrong there is no climate crisis and
he's creating a unifying enemy to try
and create a moral structure around for
the sake of globalism I think he thinks
there is a climate crisis I think he
believes the if you read the um the UN
reports on on the climate and and the
the the he takes the worst scenarios uh
they're usually written as unlikely or
highly unlikely but he'll take the worst
case scenarios and think we need to do
something about this so I I'm not sure
how
a good as far as you can have good faith
with Cloud Schwab right a good faith
scenario is that he really believes that
well this he'll do anything to guys this
this has me scared
we gotta help Obama we got to help him
he he must not know this he bought a
waterfront property in Martha's Vineyard
someone's got to send send him an email
as he texted me earlier he's let him
freak it out
there Billy boobs Gates also beachfront
property oh no do they know we gotta
help him well the thing is let him know
that the water levels are gonna run
there could be a climate catastrophe if
we do nothing but the problem with these
models is they don't take into account
mitigating factors changes in technology
a little carbon capture I got an answer
for you guys in all seriousness when
everyone says if there really was a
climate catastrophe why would Bill Gates
and Barack Obama and many others buy
waterfront property and my my answer is
it's simple because you will own nothing
and you will be happy their plan is I
can own this waterfront property because
we're going to solve the problem by
taking away everything from you yeah
we're gonna solve it but and I justify
it because I'm buying the carbon credits
I Can Fly they're identifying everything
they don't need to justify anything if
if let's say it's this it let's say this
it is a fact ocean levels will rise if
we do nothing
Barack Obama and Bill Gates are like oh
but we are going to do something we're
going to take away the property rights
of the regular working people
that will solve the ocean level crisis
and I can buy my property but how will
that solve the crisis if humans stop
consuming and stop producing and stop
reproducing and have all their property
taken away the mentality is this will
avert the climate crisis meaning the
powerful Elites are allowed to keep
their property keep their Jets keep
their cars so it's not that Obama
doesn't believe it's happening he just
believes he's going to win or or he
doesn't actually believe that there is a
climate catastrophe in the same way that
they all take private jets to get to
Davos if they truly believed it they
wouldn't take the Privacy this might
could be the same same phenomenon they
don't actually I believe I die down this
is my point
I think it's possible they do believe it
and it's simply it's simple enough that
they're saying okay if we all keep
flying on private jets it's bad for the
environment so let's take away the
property rights of the poor people so we
don't have to stop get it John I get it
but no I was just saying John Kerry
actually recently got confronted what
you know how do you justify flying
private so often and he just point blank
said like I buy the carbon credits to
offset it and he thought that it was all
good the carbon credit is a total scam
as well if you'd like dig into that
stuff it's almost impossible to
guarantee the carbon credits they've got
to let's say You're Building trees
you've got to find a country that's
politically stable that the trees can
last 30 40 50 it actually grow if you
dig into that stuff it's a total Con
well so I want to ask you because you
know you're reading Cloud Schwab's book
is this a new phenomenon or like did
something happen to wake you up because
I'm just imagining you're hanging out
with your band and and they're you know
writing a song and then just over beers
you're like have you guys read this
Klaus Schwab stuff and they're like
Winston what are you talking about uh I
I've been concerned about uh uh Davos
and the WF for a long time I'd say
basically a analogy to to elitist
certainly in elitists unelected
ungetable types like I I've had that and
my family and you know I have
journalists in the family and this is
the kind of conversations we have so
I've been interested in that stuff a
long time and I think just like seems
like you you fellas you see the stuff
they say like you'll be you'll earn
nothing you'll be happy and you think
bloody hell what the hell is this and
why on Earth are my elected officials
why is my prime minister going to Davos
why is it it's almost likely that the
the labor party will be in power in
Britain and Kirsten who's later leader
of the labor party he was off at Davos
why are these people all going and in
the conversation with these unelected
Elites like Cloud Schwab who you can't
get rid of who are dictating the
conversation why are they going there
it's the Coachella politics it's exactly
like that you know it would be cool
though if like at Davos in their highly
secured facility is this machine called
the progenitor device that connects to
base reality outside the simulation
where all the world leaders communicate
with the 17 year old who's playing Sim
Earth
that's just that's just it you know
nothing nothing there's no big
conspiracy well the occult is a big part
of people that get really really rich
and they have no not much more to gain
they start going inward uh maybe Luke
you can explain more about that I know I
I've seen stuff I've read stuff I don't
know for sure Luke is Bohemian Grove
still happening uh yes so so is the
Bilderberg meeting but the Bilderberg is
not nearly as occult as but hold on hold
on we know of I gotta say this remember
that Bilderberg was a conspiracy theory
yeah this is the first they first first
told us it doesn't exist and if you
think it does exist you're a crazy
conspiracy theorist then they said oh it
does exist but nothing really happens
there it's just the world's most
powerful people coming together in
secret meeting together and having off
the Record meetings as they arrest
members of the press like myself trying
to report on it nothing to see there and
then they're like oh yeah little tidbits
here from The New York Times The
Washington Post admitting that this is
where politicians are selected to be
vice president this is where major
decisions are being met uh made
specifically with the larger
geopolitical effective at Bilderberg
last year there was a NATO member that
that was able to of course achieve NATO
member status that was first discussed
at this Bilderberg meeting I'm going to
look at the particular details of that
and get back to you guys here in a
little bit but as you were saying bill
it's not that they're playing politics
politics is just theater to them they're
playing a whole different game a whole
different perspective here and what you
guys are joking about is the actual
serious things that they're discussing
gives lectures about how there's going
to be useless human beings out there and
how we need to pacify them by giving
them drugs and video games and when we
look at what's happening when we look at
what's happening in society well yes
he's wrong he's absolutely he's
absolutely wrong but because they're the
ones building the the technological uh
advancements they're the ones a part of
the fourth Industrial Revolution
creating this situation where we have
the haves and haves not I just want to
point this out though I don't believe
the the end result that these people are
preaching is the appropriate response
but I certainly think there is a
cognitive dissonance in complaining
about the woke cult but then also saying
there aren't useless people out there I
guess you can say that the woke cult is
the useful people for these these
autocrats and dictatorial warmongers
they want a Mindless zombie horde to do
their bidding but I look at it like we I
think we do have a problem I'm not going
to sit here and tell you I know
everything about climate change I don't
I think it's it's plausible that over
consumption can lead to any kind of
pollution or environmental disruption I
think that's a fair point I'm not going
to pretend like I know enough and I
don't trust people who buy beachfront
property and then tell me to sell you
know sell my car or whatever but I also
think you go to these big cities and you
will see nothing but useless people and
I'm not trying to be a dick I'm not
trying they don't have to be useless but
the problem is many of them are listless
and purposeless and then they seek out
authoritarianism they support the worst
of the worst ideologies they actively
disrupt and Destroy so not that I agree
with that guy who's kind of a
nightmarish despot I do think it's
important to point out we have a
cultural problem in the U.S where we
have a large swath of people who don't
contribute anything but just drag the
system down combine that with the fact
that they also don't have a God right so
they they they get behind let's say it's
the work religion or the
environmentalist religion all these
different quasi pseudo-religions filling
the void and they have meaningless lives
there's a serious issue that we have to
address we have to find create
meaningful lives for people so in that
sense much as you all know that Noah
Harari puts my back up and get very
nervous of the stuff he says that I
think you're right we have a meaning
meaning
purpose crisis in the west thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time